Google Gemini new free updates are
insane. Google Gemini just dropped six
massive updates at the same time and
nobody is talking about it. We're
talking custom music, smarter reasoning,
better images, video templates, deep
research, and real scientific citations.
All free, all inside Gemini. And today
I'm going to break down every single one
so you can start using them right now.
Let's get into it. So the first update
is wild. It's called LIA 3. And what it
does is let you generate custom
soundtracks right inside Gemini. Not
like some basic beat. I'm talking about
real music tracks 30 seconds long. And
here's what makes it crazy. You don't
just type in a prompt. You can feed it
an image. You can feed it a video and it
matches the vibe automatically. Think
about that for a second. You're making a
YouTube short. You need background
music. Instead of going to some other
tool, instead of searching through a
library, you just tell Gemini what mood
you want and it builds the track for
you. It's like having a music producer
sitting inside your browser. And it's in
beta right now, so you can try it today.
This is huge for content creators, huge
for anyone making reels, huge for anyone
running ads. You describe a feeling
Gemini gives you a soundtrack. That
simple. But that's just the creative
side. Let me show you what's happening
on the brain side. Hey, if we haven't
met already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Okay, so
update number two, Gemini 3.1 Pro. This
is the reasoning upgrade, and this one
is serious. See, most people use AI for
simple stuff. Write me an email, give me
a recipe, that's fine. But 3.1 Pro is
built for the hard stuff. We're talking
complex problems, multi-step thinking,
taking a bunch of messy data and turning
it into one clear picture. So imagine
you've got 12 different research sources
all saying different things. 3.1 Pro can
pull all of that together into one
unified view. It can break down complex
models visually. It can explain things
step by step in a way that actually
makes sense. This is not your average
chatbot upgrade. This turns Gemini into
a real research assistant, a strategy
tool, an engineering brain. If you're
building a business, if you're doing any
kind of research, if you're solving
problems that have a lot of moving
parts, this is the update that matters
most. Now, let me show you the image
upgrade. And yes, the name is funny.
It's called Nano Banana 2. I know, but
don't let the name fool you. This thing
is a beast. So, what's different? Nano
Banana 2 gives you higher quality
images, more realistic, more consistent,
and faster. Before, AI images had that
weird look to them. You could always
tell hands were off, faces look strange,
things just felt a little fake. Nano
Banana 2 fixes a lot of that. It
understands the real world better. So
when you ask it to create something, it
looks like it actually belongs in the
real world. This matters if you're a
marketer, if you're a designer, if you
run an agency, if you make content for
social media. You're going from images
that look AI generated to images that
look like they came from a real shoot.
That's a big jump. And it's all inside
Gemini for free. Now, here's where I
want to pause for a second. If you're
watching this and thinking, "Wow, I want
to actually use all these tools to grow
my business, to automate things, to get
more customers," then you need to check
out the AI Profit Boardroom. It's the
best place to learn how to use AI tools
like Gemini to scale your business and
save hundreds of hours with automation.
I'll drop the link in the comments and
description. Go check it out. All right,
let's keep going. Update number five, VO
3.1 templates. Now, this one is about
making video creation easier. Before, if
you wanted to use VO, you needed to know
how to prompt. You needed to be good at
describing exactly what you wanted. And
that's a skill. Not everyone has it, but
now they added templates.
You can browse a whole gallery, pick a
style you like, remix it, add your own
details, and boom, you've got a video.
This is like going from a blank page to
a coloring book. The structure is
already there. You just fill in the fun
parts. This makes Gemini way more
beginner friendly, way faster, and way
more creative because sometimes you
don't know what you want until you see
it. And templates let you start from
something instead of nothing. Okay, now
this next one, this is the big brain
update. Deepthink mode just got
upgraded. And if you're a researcher, an
engineer, a data analyst, pay attention
because this is built for you. Deepthink
mode in Gemini 3 can now interpret
complex data sets. It can model physical
systems. It can write code for
simulations and it can drive real world
applications. This isn't casual AI. This
is academic grade reasoning, engineering
level modeling. This is the kind of tool
that used to require and a whole team
and now it's sitting inside Gemini free.
Let me give you an example. Say you're
trying to understand how a system works
like a supply chain or a physics model.
Deep Think can break that down, build it
out, show you how the pieces connect,
and do it at a level that actually holds
up to scrutiny. That's powerful. And
that brings us to the last update. And
honestly,
this might be the most important one for
trust. Gemini now gives you real
scientific citations, direct links to
actual papers, verified sources
connected to the claims it makes. Why
does this matter so much? Because AI
hallucinations are a real problem. You
ask AI something, it sounds confident,
but it just made it up. That's
dangerous. Especially if you're doing
research, writing a paper, making a
business decision based on data. You
need to know the source is real. Now,
Gemini links you straight to the paper.
You can check it yourself. You can
verify. You can trust what it's telling
you. This makes Gemini way more useful
for students, for researchers, for
anyone who needs sourcebacked answers.
It's not just smart now. It's
trustworthy. So, let me bring this all
together because I want you to see the
full picture here. Gemini is no longer
just a chatbot. It's now a music
generator with LIA 3. It's a reasoning
engine with 3.1 Pro. It's a highquality
image model with Nano Banana 2. It's a
video remix tool with Veo 3.1 templates.
It's a deep research assistant with
upgraded deep think. And it's a
citationbacked academic helper with
verified sources. And most of this is
free. That's what's wild about this.
Google is quietly turning Gemini into a
full AI operating system, a creative
stack, a research stack, a production
engine, all in one place, and they just
keep shipping. If you're a creator, use
LIA 3 and Nano Banana 2. If you're a
researcher,
use Deepthink and the new citations.
If you're building a business, use 3.1
Pro to think through complex problems.
If you're making videos,
use Veo templates. There's something
here for everyone. Now, if you want to
take this even further, if you want to
learn how to use AI tools like Gemini to
automate your workflows, get more
customers, and save hundreds of hours,
join the AI profit boardroom. I'll put
the link right in the comments in the
description. It's the best place to
learn how to actually apply these tools
to grow your business. Don't sleep on
it. And one more thing before you go. If
you want the full process, the SOPs, and
over a 100 AI use cases just like this
one, you need to join the AI Success
Lab. It's our free community, and it's
not just some random group. We've got
over 38,000 members in there right now
who are using AI every single day to
work smarter and get better results.
You'll get all the video notes from this
video in there. You'll get breakdowns of
every tool I talk about. You'll get
templates, workflows, step-by-step
guides, and you'll be surrounded by
people who are actually doing this
stuff, not just watching videos about
it. The link is in the comments and the
description. It's free to join. There's
no catch. Just go in there, introduce
yourself, and start learning. I promise
you, it's one of the best AI communities
on the internet right now. And I'm not
just saying that. 38,000 people can't be
wrong. Make sure you subscribe, hit the
bell, and drop a comment below telling
me which Gemini update you're most
excited about. Julian reads every single
one.